elle fait partie des députés qui n'ont
pas tardé à se faire un nom dans la
nouvelle Assemblée une ascension rapide
mais pas si surprenante quand on sait
que mon invité a fait ses armes aux
côtés d'une ancienne ministre
aujourd'hui mère d'une grande ville
[Musique]
bonjour violette spielboot bonjour alors
vous avez pratiqué la danse classique
avec l'espoir de devenir danseuse
étoiles de tout cela il reste une
médaille du Conservatoire de Lille
quelques photos et un témoignage vidéo
assez inattendu on va en voir un extrait
la tête gonflée de projet elle jubile
perçue dès que ses ambitions se
réaliseront dans sa région
ma région donne l'impulsion à mon
ambition
[Musique]
ordonnance
recrutement justement ma région donne
l'impulsion à ma vocation
[Musique]
alors on reconnaît bien le côté années
90 dans cette vidéo c'était un clip de
promotion de la région
Nord-Pas-de-Calais tourné quand vous
aviez 17 ans je crois c'est ça
parce que au début
dans cette vidéo on a presque
l'impression que la voix off qu'on
entend parler là elle parle de vos
propres ambitions vos ambitions
politiques pour la région pour la ville
de Lille oui c'est incroyable parce que
quand on se replonge il y a 30 ans j'ai
une cinquantaine d'années on voit cette
ambition globale de notre région des
Hauts de France de l'île capital
régionale et je me retrouve depuis
quelques années
politique donc j'imagine oui que c'était
mon destin et ça me correspond bien
aujourd'hui sur la danse classique vous
l'avez pratiqué quand même à haut niveau
on dit souvent que c'est une discipline
c'est un enseignement très dur qui peut
forger une personnalité pour le reste de
sa vie est-ce que est-ce que c'est votre
cas ah je le crois profondément la danse
classique c'est d'abord la discipline la
rigueur et l'effort moi ça m'a beaucoup
appris aussi pour le collectif parce que
la danse classique moderne sa pratique
dans une équipe dans une troupe et donc
ce travail collectif cette harmonie qui
doit être trouvé je le retrouve
finalement dans ma vie professionnelle
puis politique aujourd'hui alors vous
avez fait vos débuts dans le milieu
politique un peu par hasard si l'on peut
dire il y avait un poste à pourvoir au
cabinet du maire de l'île de l'époque
Pierre Mauroy c'était en 1997 c'est
assez coté donc que vous avez débuté
mais c'est surtout avec Martine Aubry
que vous avez fait votre apprentissage
si l'on peut dire pendant 13 ans vous
avez été chef de cabinet puis directrice
de cabinet de la mère de Lille qu'est-ce
que vous avez appris au côté de Martine
Aubry ah j'ai beaucoup appris sur la
conduite de la politique locale de la
politique pour une grande ville ça veut
dire à la fois la construction d'une
vision et puis tous les sujets
opérationnels les sujets de crise quand
on est maire d'une ville on est apporté
d'engueulade c'est à dire à disposition
permanente des concitoyens j'ai
utiliserons auprès de Martine Aubry en
commençant de mon concours d'ingénieur
territorial et effectivement en ayant
occupé le poste de directrice de cabinet
pendant son son mandat jusque en 2014
moi ça m'a appris la gestion des du
quotidien d'une grande ville et de ses
relations avec son territoire son
environnement donc c'est beaucoup de
bons souvenirs professionnels pour moi
alors fin 2013 vous êtes parti
travailler à la SNCF mais il était prévu
que vous vous présentiez l'année
suivante aux côtés de Martine Aubry au
municipales et voulait même faire de
vous son adjointe à l'éducation sauf
qu'en janvier 2014 coup de théâtre vous
lui dites non c'est totalement inattendu
ça surprend tout le monde ça ressemble
presque à un refus d'obstacle au moment
où vous a proposé de basculer en tant
que femme politique c'est qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pour moi c'était pas un
recul c'était plutôt une avancée une
décision courageuse dans ma vie j'avais
40 ans et vous savez à 40 ans souvent on
fait le point sur ce qui est important
en termes de valeur d'engagement et
j'avais beaucoup de sujets en fait qui
me heurtaient
et qui progressivement dans la maturité
de de ma compréhension de de l'ensemble
des enjeux politiques locaux et
nationaux me poser problème des
désaccords politiques sur les rythmes
éducatifs c'était la grande époque de
des relations avec les parents d'élèves
très tendus sur l'imposition du samedi
matin pour pour faire l'école
il y avait les sujets culturels bien sûr
qui m'ont beaucoup de mobilisé et puis
la relation au commerce à
l'entrepreneuriat on avait une défiance
du maire de Lille plus en plus de plus
en plus prononcée envers les commerçants
les artisans de la ville et tous ces
sujets là ont fait que vers 40 ans au
moment de m'engager ou pas dans cette
liste municipale j'ai choisi de rester à
la SNCF et de me dissocier avec des
sujets aussi de valeur d'injustice qui
me posait problème alors vous avez
poursuivi votre carrière à la SNCF comme
directrice des relations publiques à
l'époque et puis un jour en 2016 en
descendant les escaliers dans le métro
je crois que vous êtes gravement blessé
au mollet
ça a été une épreuve longue
la vitesse politique à laquelle on agit
aujourd'hui alors vous avez fini
heureusement par vous en remettre et le
22 janvier 2018 vous êtes apparu au
premier rang des vœux de l'opposition
municipale à la mer de Lille donc les
vœux de la droite alors le message est
clair vous entrez en politique et alors
là vous le faites compte celles auprès
de qui vous avez grandi c'est une
décision que vous avez mûri pendant
votre convalescence c'est quelque chose
qui vous trottait dans la tête ou
l'engagement politique qui m'a titillée
on va dire au moment où Emmanuel Macron
en 2016 c'est engagé et a proposé cette
nouvelle offre qui faisait confiance à
la société civile qui était dans le
déplacement des clivages et dans toute
cet élan des présidentielles puis des
législatives moi j'étais dans ma
convalescence donc effectivement j'ai lu
beaucoup et tout ça m'a permis
effectivement de à un moment avec les
rencontres des Lillois et qui m'ont
accompagné d'oser d'oser proposer plutôt
une offre politique nouvelle celle de la
majorité présidentielle à Lille pour les
Lillois et pour la métropole chinoise
c'était un moment effectivement un peu
surprenant pour certains mais qui
étaient déjà bien mûr chez moi depuis de
nombreuses années alors avant de pouvoir
vous présenter face à Martine aubryon
municipale vous avez quand même dû vous
imposer dans votre propre camp parce
qu'il y avait la députée lrem de
l'époque Valérie petit qui voulait aussi
se présenter vous l'avez battu lors de
l'investiture vous l'avez à nouveau
battu quand il a fait lubriguer
l'investiture au législatif la campagne
ces deux campagnes ce sont déroulées
dans un climat très tendu vous assumez
une forme de dureté en politique c'est
non je dirais plutôt que je subis une
forme de dureté et de violence en
politique pendant la campagne municipale
notamment on a vu beaucoup de violences
verbales
à mon local de campagne des menaces de
mort beaucoup de diffamations sur les
réseaux sociaux mais sans violence
contre mais ça c'est ce que beaucoup
d'élus aujourd'hui
rencontrent on le voit moi je pense que
on est dans une ville dans un territoire
qui était très tenue par un système
c'est les Baronnies dans les grandes
villes françaises et nous on apporte
aujourd'hui avec la majorité
présidentielle une nouvelle offre
politique et tout ça effectivement ça
dérange donc quand on dérange on doit se
battre un peu moi j'estime que avec des
bonnes armes il y a quand même un côté
dur chez vous enfin se présenter parce
que vous vous êtes présenté donc au
municipale face à Martine Aubry vous
avez perdu vous avez fait comme plus de
20 % je crois au second tour face à elle
mais c'est quand même dur de se
présenter face à celle qui vous a fait
grandir qui vous a introduit dans le
milieu politique vous comprenez qu'elle
soit senti trahis Martine Aubry moi je
ne me suis jamais présenté pour être
contre je me suis présentée avec un vrai
projet collectif tout le projet
municipal qu'on a construit c'était avec
l'ensemble des associations des acteurs
de la société civile des commerçants des
infirmiers des profs qui étaient à mes
côtés des chefs d'entreprise et qui
avait envie de changer le visage de
l'île et sa vision métropolitaine
je suis lilloise depuis toute petite
j'ai fait de la Lille j'ai fait le
conservatoire à Lille je pense qu'on
peut promouvoir aujourd'hui une
candidature pour avoir un maire de Lille
et qui porte une vision de la ville et
de la métropole très ambitieuse avec une
vraie vision municipale et nationale
pour notre ville de Lille alors vous
faites pas de cadeau en politique malgré
tout mais la politique vous l'avez dit
vous fait pas de cadeau non plus il y a
eu ces incidents pendant la campagne des
municipales lors de vos réunions
publiques il y a eu d'autres événements
pendant la réforme des retraites une
fois une fois élu députée il y a des
manifestants qui sont présentés devant
votre domicile avec des drapeaux des
banderoles mais aussi avec des parpaings
et du ciment
alors ces manifestants qu'on voit ils
ont muré la porte d'entrée de votre
domicile et puis il y a ses champs qu'on
vient d'entendre tout le monde déteste
les spiles boots comment est-ce que vous
avez vécu ce moment alors je vais juste
rectifier le chant bien écouter on la
réécouté plusieurs fois et compris avec
la police c'est tout le monde déteste
violet speedbout pour moi c'est très
important c'est très important
pour ma famille pour mes filles parce
que c'est assez émouvant en fait
d'entendre le chant plus que le mur ça
nous a tourné c'est ça qui a tourné sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est ça qui a
heurté beaucoup ma famille qui rentre
dans l'intime qui rentre dans le
jugement personnel alors que
l'engagement politique c'est le mien
c'est celui de la femme violette speed
boost
dans la maison celle qui était présente
non plus elle avait un examen du bac
l'après-midi ce genre d'action qui se
veut symbolique est réalité une vraie
violence psychologique et ce que moi
j'ai vécu on n'est pas dans la violence
physique là ce que j'ai vécu c'était
extrêmement fort c'est extrêmement fort
pour ma famille et je crois que là c'est
vraiment ce genre d'acte qui sont en
plus revendiquer ou non dénoncé par des
syndicats comme la CGT à Lille moi j'ai
écrit à Sophie Binet et elle ne m'a pas
répondu pour dénoncer cet acte Amon
domicile bien c'est le symbole qu'on
peut qu'on a dépassé une borne celle du
domicile et de la sphère privée des élus
et moi je porte beaucoup de propositions
avec mes collègues députés pour pour
apporter des solutions à à la protection
et à la sécurité des élus et de leur
famille alors on va passer au quiz après
un moment un peu plus léger si vous
voulez bien il s'agit de compléter des
phrases que je vais que je vais
commencer
on y va le plus dur quand on est
porte-parole
c'est d'être convaincu tout le temps
partout et d'être convaincu de la parole
que vous devez porter c'est à dire parce
que parfois on a des doutes parfois on
n'est pas d'accord et on doit être loyal
donc c'est un exercice que j'espère
faire avec beaucoup de sincérité et
d'authenticité
à l'Assemblée pour les prochaines
municipales à Lille je
serai si tout va bien candidate à la
mairie de Lille ce n'est pas une annonce
officielle mais c'est en tout cas un
projet que je porte et que je continue
de porter avec le collectif fait
respirer l'île autour de moi enfin quand
les gens me comparent à Brie vente de
camps est-ce que vous connaissez
brillant de compte oui je connais
personnage
quand on quand on me raconte ça c'est
souvent un qualificatif physique donc je
le prends plutôt comme un compliment
chez qu'elle a mauvais caractère
après voilà je pense que le sujet c'est
l'engagement politique et c'est pas être
acteur de cinéma merci beaucoup violette
spielboot d'être venu dans la politique
et moi merci
[Musique]